nous jouons au jeu ou nous mourons
nous avons eu de la chance de sortir vivants de ces
salles d'évasion j'ai besoin de savoir que les
criminels qui ont tué les quatre personnes
devant moi sont tenus responsables
nous nous cachons à la vue de tous au
milieu de Manhattan nous  Je dois les arrêter, je suis
dedans, je
sais que c'est beaucoup demander mais merci
d'être venu avec moi,
entends-tu que, bon sang, qu'est-ce qui
se passe,
tu vas te moquer de moi,
attends,
bienvenue dans les salles d'évasion de Mino, non.  non non,
ça se reproduit, vous avez
déjà joué au jeu, alors qu'est-ce que c'est
comme un tournoi de champions
[Applaudissements] écoutez,
nous savons tous comment cela fonctionne, nous avons
résolu les énigmes ou nous sommes morts, la
fausse publicité doit être retirée, cette publicité
vous-même manque un e  alors peut-être qu'on
tire les poignées correspondantes avec une
lettre manquante
oui,
[ __ ] d'Henry
allez, on n'a pas le temps
[Musique]
c'est bien plus gros que la dernière fois
tu dois essayer quelque chose,
oui, il y
a une raison particulière pour laquelle chacun de nous
a survécu,
je peux'  Je ne ressens pas de douleur physique, imagine juste
le genre d'énigmes qu'ils ont imaginées
pour moi,
prends une photo, ça durera plus longtemps, trouve
des indices,
cela ressemble au phare sur
la carte postale,
c'est fini, j'ai fini de courir,
nous pouvons les battre à leur propre jeu.  qu'est-ce qui
te fait penser qu'ils vont te laisser
repartir libre
[Musique]
nous allons nous faire tuer
je ne joue pas à ton jeu pas
maintenant
plus jamais
nous en avons besoin nous l'avons fait
je ne comprends pas nous'  tu es toujours dans le
jeu